listen the song of the year for me thank
you next I sang it every day
thanks I bought it Ariana Grande is here
my ponytail queen I am so happy for you
this year what does it mean to be here
at the Grammys with these major
nominations um it means matches in honor
and it's you know it's insane because
you know we didn't really even mean to
really make this album it just kind of
happened because my friends and I were
trying to help ourselves out of a very
trying time and very horrible time and
it was kind of an accident so to see be
received and celebrated this way that's
very nice it's very nice but everyone's
done incredibly this year I'm like
looking around like I'm not allowed to
say that
I'm okay that's okay you know we got you
we got you two seconds I I do want a mic
drop
I do want ask you about this fabulous
gown your stylist la Rocha cents and
right here Taemin the skirt okay so so
here's the thing I did the carpet in
custom Jon batiste dry up and I was I
loved him and they loved it so much and
then I didn't do the interview yeah and
so I came back in a different dress
because
because you're our Monday that's why the
pop star students know I bet I couldn't
decide I was so lucky you liked the boat
I had two very special custom looks me
yeah and so I couldn't decide this one
is stop Adelie yeah it's not supposed to
be said like that but I'm Italian so I
said everything sound more Italian yeah
so yeah I am
I was indecisive and decided to do it
twice I love it but that's a really huge
progress for me because usually I cannot
come within three feet of a red carpet
without having a nervous this is old hat
for you I feel like I met you when you
were very young and you were nervous on
the carpet and now you're just owning it
everyone's yelling for you we re
beautiful
[Music]